- You snooze, you win.
(laughs)
- I am very known to oversleep.
I hit snooze all the time.
- That extra nine minutes,
two minutes, is just glorious.
- When I wake up in the morning
and I know that I have to go to work
I just want to curl up in a ball and die.
- I will also set multiple alarms
and this Sleeping Beauty is not having it.
No matter how determined
I am when I go to bed.
- Snoozing for life, baby.
- You're telling me this is bad for us?
- [Woman Off Camera] I'm
going to have you guys read
some facts about snoozing.
They're not great...
- [Narrator] Snoozing
confuses your body and mind
about whether or not it's time to get up.
This may cause "sleep inertia,"
which can leave you groggy
for up to four hours after waking.
- That makes a lot of sense.
- Isn't that what coffee's for?
Right?
To get you going?
- I don't drink coffee.
- I do feel this, like,
lagging sense of I'm tired.
- I really don't feel my body waking up
until like 1:00 or 2:00.
So I guess this fact kinda feels like
it's very accurate when
it comes to my life.
- I feel totally fine and
I snoozed this morning.
Totally fine.
- [Narrator] Snoozing throws
off your internal clock,
causing your body not to
know when to become sleepy,
pushing your bedtime later,
and leading to more snoozing.
- Hmm, that's interesting
'cause you know I actually
have trouble falling asleep.
- My internal clock is fucked up anyway
because you know during the week
we have to wake up early to get to work.
And on the weekends I'll go out late
and be out with friends,
drinking or hanging out
or doing whatever and then, like,
I'll be in bed 'til 11 or noon.
- I wish I had an earlier bedtime.
I have trouble with that.
So maybe the snoozing is affecting it.
But I doubt it.
- [Narrator] Messing
up your internal clocks
makes for restless nights,
and sleep deprivation can
screw up hundreds of genes
that regulate your immune
system, stress response
and metabolism.
- Wow, that took a turn.
I don't know why I was
reading that so joyfully,
that's a bummer.
- I'm not a scientist, but no.
- My immune system definitely
got worse over the years
and it's funny 'cause as I've gotten older
I've gotten less sleep.
- Maybe that's why I'm always stressed?
- I've noticed the
nights where I got, like,
a shitty night's sleep or
like snoozed a lot, whatever,
that I was more anxious and stressed out
at work the next day.
- I think the concept of me
somehow snoozing my alarm clock
changing my genes is scary,
but because it's so scary, I
choose not to believe that.
I don't think it's true.
- Screwing up genes like a sale at Macy's.
- [Narrator] Scientists
believe these genetic changes
can potentially increase
your risk of heart disease,
weight gain or diabetes.
- I feel like I need
to be in the hospital.
Like somebody call me
an ambulance right now.
- Doesn't everything cause you to die?
- Yeah.
- Right?
- We're all slowly dying from all things.
So, like, who cares?
- If your friends want
to hang out with you
and you want to go to sleep
and they make you feel bad about it.
Just be, like, you're very
much impacting my health
and future so let me sleep.
- You're giving me heart disease, Dennis.
That's what you're doing.
- [Narrator] According to
neuroscientist Matthew Walker,
hitting snooze causes
"cardiovascular assault"
on your heart each time it goes off.
- Oh my gosh.
- Somebody call the police.
- Square up, I guess.
- Bitch, I believe it's
a mini heart attack.
Every time I hear it, every
time I hear my alarm go off
I jump four feet into the air.
- I'm really scared about hitting snooze.
I feel like next time I hit snooze
I'm going to see my life
flash before my eyes.
(laughs)
And I'm going to be
like alright, it's fine,
Jesus, I'll get up.
- I feel like neuroscientists
are trying to tell me
how to live my life when
they don't even know me.
- I wish I was more scared
but I'm still going to
continue to hit snooze.
Like, honestly, I mean,
it's been a pattern
and an on-going thing for years.
How am I going to stop
even with these facts?
- In a perfect world,
I wouldn't have to wake
up in the morning, like,
I could just sleep until my body is ready.
And wouldn't that be like the
healthiest thing for my body.
But I have to make money.
I have to live, neuroscientists.
- You have to live in this society.
- But it's surprising
like the severity of stuff
that it can lead to and overall
I'm still inclined to think
it's not like that big of a deal
and I'm still going to face
my own internal struggle
of waking up to get to the gym anyway.
- Keep snoozing until the day I die.
And then that day I can't snooze.
- Snooze til you die.
- Yeah.
- Just do the best you can.
- In this lifetime what more can you do?
- If you're a snoozer you're not a loser.
That's all I gotta say.
- I like that.
I want a shirt that says that.